screws face the floor here but he's got
to be aware of Derek white on the Quick
Pass back also
white will inbound
[Applause]
it's off the small room for the seventh
game
but the buzzer sounded the light was on
it'll be reviewed
I don't think he got that in time great
effort by Derek white and didn't I say
you hell they're saying on the floor
they're counting it you have to protect
the offensive rebound oh he got rid of
it
[Applause]
good basket the plays under review
White
what a finish to this game
stunned people here are absolutely
stunned a rush shot that went in and out
by the way by Marcus Mark that's what
allowed Derek white the offensive
rebounding opportunity bucket good we're
headed to beontown for a game seven and
what has been an improbable Eastern
Conference Final
and Boston becomes the fourth team ever
down three games tonight to force a game
seven and the first one of those teams
to get a shot to complete it at home the
other three were on the road
[Applause]
[Music]
white got it game-winning basket
white finishes with 11 let's go to Ali
lafour